welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Domingo Cavallo in Argentine
economist and politician and a senior
fellow at Yale's Jackson Institute for
Global Affairs currently the chairman
and CEO of DFC associates mr. Cavallo
was Argentina's minister of economy from
1991 to 1996 and in 2001 and minister of
foreign affairs from nineteen eighty
nine to nineteen ninety one he was
elected national congressman on two
occasions and also served as chairman of
the Central Bank of Argentina in 1982
today we talked with him about
argentina's economy welcome mr. Cavallo
he's a pleasure to hear economist Carlos
melkonian recently described the
Argentine economic situation as a
ticking time bomb despite record highs
in terms of consumption and production
what do you think of that
characterization I think here right
because this record high level of
activity came as a consequence of
extremely expulsion Airy monetary and
fiscal policies and very favorable
external conditions particularly the
most favorable terms of trade for
Argentina in all its history and the
government has been implementing
procyclical policies and it has
introduced a lot of distortions in into
the economy by trying to control some
prices a has been increasingly using
restrictions to to imports to protect
local industry and has been taxing
agriculture very heavily and all that
has created a situation which is very
complicated a actually inflation is very
high much higher than what the
government says that it is because
actually my government is lying on
inflation statistics inflation is around
25 percent para known and that is very
very high and there are many distortions
into the economy right now in order to
to try to keep a trade surplus the
economic authorities have been
implementing restrictions to imports and
also to payments of dividends and
sending money abroad so although
restriction will introduce additional
distortions and I think as a carlo
mcconnell said it's a sort of bomb the
time bomb that is in place they are in
it may burst at any time so do the
people of Argentina because of the
production and consumption rates being
so good are they happy with the things
that they are happy with the way things
are at this point yes if you look at the
electoral results of you see that the
government gets a fifty-four percent of
support according to to the pole saw
people looks like be happy with this
situation and there is always a period
in which a higher higher inflation looks
like a good for the people when the
government may authorize which increases
salary increases and increases also in
nominal pensions but then a when it
comes to the
to the moment in which the authority
have to put brakes to prevent the
acceleration of inflation an
expansionary fiscal monetary policy have
to be reversed there will be a recession
and I think at that time people will
realize that this was not sustainable
development in Argentina right right how
big of a problem do you think capital
flight is unsure oh it's a very
important problem actually capital I had
been happening since 2007 and so far I
think more than 50 billion dollar have
flight from Argentina to the rest of the
world and is not investment by
Argentinian companies abroad which which
would be a good development but it is
simply people that feel that they are
not secure in Argentina and they move
their capital abroad so that restricts
the financing of new investment in
Argentina so it's a big problem and
actually the government tries to prevent
that by imposing more and more controls
unimportant on exportation of capital
bad those controls discourage people
from keeping her capital in Argentina so
the end result is is very bad capital
flight continues at very high levels ok
and what about the subsidies the current
administration is handing out how is
that part of the problem oh yes he has
big big fiscal problem as a part of the
fiscal expansion excessive fiscal
sponsor came because the government
compensated the public utility fridge or
the freezer public utility rates by a
pain subsidy stone to the companies but
that has grown to become a
a very very big expenditure item in the
budget and now the government has to
reduce that but you know in order to
remove those subsidy it has to let the
public utility rates to increase by one
hundred percent two hundred percent in
some cases I mean water supply natural
gas electricity and of course all those
sudden price increases or a will will
impact and will produce additional
inflation now so that is a big problem
in but the elimination of the subsidies
of the reduction of the success is very
necessary otherwise the fiscal deficit
will become unmanageable know so it's
daddy's a consequence of Rome policies
of the past that are now provoking this
this effects so do you think the
government doesn't want to to take back
the subsidies because the prices are
going to go up and then they know but
they actually they have started to take
back the subsidies gradually because
they cannot afford any more to continue
paying all these subsidies the fiscal
deficit is already too big na but of
course as a consequence of removing the
subsidies there are already and there
will be even more price increases know
so that is a problem but it's something
that the the government has to to do in
a problem it has to face because it came
or it originated in bad policies of the
past is there a big public outcry
because they're doing oh yes not so big
big because until now they have removed
the subsidies only for supply of public
services in rich neighborhoods but to
the extent that it goes into
neighborhoods were the middle classes or
the low-income people lives i think the
outcry will be
tremendous tremendous yes what about the
agricultural business how big of a role
is that playing oh it's very important
you know Argentina was always very rich
in natural resources particularly for
for agriculture and until the 50s
argentina had a very efficient
agriculture and export oriented
agriculture then during the peronist
government and for almost a 45 year from
mid 40s until nineteen ninety
agriculture was discouraged by heavy
taxation and a lot of discrimination and
productivity in agriculture did not
expand in a sec consequence the whole
argentinian economy stagnated now and it
was in addition and a period of rape
rapid inflation and eventually
hyperinflation so it was very bad for
verizon tina those 45 years but since
the early 90s by the removal of all the
taxes on exports of agriculture products
the opening up of the economy the
stabilization then there was a revival
of agriculture productivity increase
very rapidly catched up with
productivity in australia in canada in
the united states mmm so our agriculture
sector became again an engine of clothes
for for argentina during the 90s in
spite of all these good development as
the international prices were very low
the benefits did not were not perceived
very clearly but during the last decade
because of the growth in china and the
high demand for soy and other
agricultural products in china the terms
of trade became very favorable for a
zentadon with that very high
productivity in agriculture and
agribusiness in general that became a
the most important engine of growth of
of argentina and also agriculture and
agribusiness in general because it's not
only production and farming but you know
the supply of inputs all the services
that the company agricultural production
plus the processing of the of the crops
of the products know all that is a very
very important activity nurse until it
creates a lot of employment well
distributed in the whole country not
concentrated Justin in the big cities so
it's a I think if Argentina eliminates
inflation implements good stabilization
policies and eliminate this destructive
taxes that unfortunately have been
reintroduced just unleashing the
potential that our Accra business has
will provide many many years of rapid
growth for our country okay so let's
talk specifically in terms of this tip
ticking time bomb so you kind of
mentioned some things that would help
for that bomb not to go off and then
what does Argentina really need to do in
order to keep its economy moving forward
to stabilize the economy in terms of
prices I mean a name right now because
of all the press controls of the past
plus the subsidies you have just a sort
of inertial inflation that comes from
then need to adjust all those prices in
addition the the wages and the salaries
have been increasing also very rapidly
that pleased the people but it increased
the cost of production in every sector
of the economy the government has been
trying to dampen the inflationary effect
of all this pricing cost increases by
controlling the exchange rate but that
it's part of the of the bomb the time
bomb because once it can not control the
exchange rate anymore that there may be
a sharp devaluation and that will add a
to the inflation so what this government
should do is to design and implement a
typical stabilization plan a plan that
will put breaks in inflation for that
purpose it has to tighten monetary
policy for some time internet will have
to go up that will have a recessionary
effect but to extend that the government
sticks to that establish a shin policy
like it happened in the United State in
the early eighties with Paul Volcker
then after one or two years as in theni
an inflation will be down most prices
will have been liberalized markets will
start operating again in a reasonable
way n if all these distorted taxes are
removed and the same time a government
expanding irreducible the elimination of
all those subsidies the economy may
become unstable economy again as it was
during the 90s with very low inflation
and all this potential that I described
coming from agribusiness another
important activity which Argentina has
comparative advantage and is efficient
as you till may grow out of the crisis
and and enjoy a very good times ahead no
but inevitable as they need to address
the inflationary problem and to remove
all these distortions and all that will
for sure provoke a something like a
burst and then a recession and only with
good stabilization policies it will
succeed in
finding the way out in a sustainable way
do you think the current administration
recognizes that there is a ticking time
bomb no unfortunately it's not
recognizing it the worst part of this
the current administration is that there
have been lying and continue lying the
very fact that they say that the
inflation rate is nine percent when
inflation is actually twenty-five
percent per annum Wow means a big
problem because the government cannot
recognize that it has a problem and if
you do not recognize that you have a
problem for sure you will not find easy
way out of that probably that that is a
mainly a political problem that we face
in urgent it so what do you think is
going to happen now I think that reality
will force the government to introduce
the necessary adjustment I am NOT very
optimist in the terms of the ability of
the government to design a good
stabilization program that will minimize
the costs it will maximize the
probabilities of success but if reality
forces the government to adopt difficult
decisions like the complete removal of
the subsidies maybe the realignment of
the exchange rate and all that once the
government sees that that is any
inevitable will work hard to try to
design a good stabilization program I
don't know that is maybe wishful
thinking but one has always to to leave
the door open for a good policies right
well thank you very much for being here
with us today and sharing some of your
work okay it has been a pleasure thank
you for more information about mr.
Cavallo please visit our website at yale
edu backslash macmillan report be sure
to join us again for another episode of
the macmillan report made possible
through funding from the whitney and
betty macmillan center for international
channel and area studies at Yale